hello YouTube I'm am veneman executive
director of UNICEF it's great to be back
with YouTube at Davos for the second
year in a row the topic it's being
discussed here at Davos this year is a
focus on the economic crisis around the
world and as we look at the economic
crisis it's very important not to forget
the world's has vulnerable those who
live on less than a dollar a day
particularly those women and children
whose lives are at risk who may not have
enough nutrition food may not have
access to essential medicines or the
opportunity for education and so as we
look at our own economic difficulties
remember that those who are most
vulnerable are likely to be impacted in
the greatest ways as we suffer from this
economic downturn thank you very much